surtout ne touche à rien ne bougeait pas
rester
dans le reste de l'actualité la rive au
18e reportage quel est le sujet que vous
avez choisi le traité est bien le
football féminin du 7 juin au 7 juillet
la coupe de football féminin en france
qu'est ce que vous voulez connaître
juste quelques questions vous voulez
poser ou quelque personne vous voulez
rencontrer
on va aller voir etienne thomas il
s'occupe de développer le foot féminin
on va rencontrer le responsable de la
section sportive du football féminin
s'est fait un peu ce que vous voulez
savoir si le foot féminin
monsieur foot féminin le foot masculin
s'ils jouent de la même manière qui m'a
dit qu'on tape on a plein de questions à
poser
il est prêt à partir allez c'est parti
pour dix huit ans
m
[Musique]
premier rendez vous de la journée pour
ribet les lamia le stade des orchamps
c'est là que les filles de la section
foot du lycée pergaud s'entraîne trois
fois par semaine la ruse
tout de suite tout de suite chercher du
regard voilà depuis bientôt vingt ans
stéphane barbeau forme des adolescentes
qui tout au départ on tue à s'imposer
dans leur club face aux garçons quand on
est petit pas moi j'ai commencé avec les
garçons donc c'est un peu compliqué
quand les garçons sont jeunes de voir
une fille qui joue avec eux dans leur
équipe ce n'est pas forcément la
personnalité on va le faire un peu plus
de passe etc
au début ça a été compliqué mais là ça a
évolué donc les gars ont changé ça
amusant que les mentalités évoluent
voilà les filles sont beaucoup plus
acceptée dans les clubs on le ressent le
perçoit au clic pour mémoire si la
première rencontre de football féminin a
eu lieu en 1917 ce n'est qu'à la fin des
années 60 que la fédération française
reconnaît la discipline
aujourd'hui les filles de pergaud
imagine qu'elle pourrait peut-être un
joueur en faire un métier comme beaucoup
de jeunes filles elle rêverait tout dans
un petit coin de leur tête je pense d un
jour professionnel
après c'est compliqué forcément de
devenir joueuse professionnelle mais il
ya quelques belles réussites part par
l'intermédiaire de la section sportive
depuis depuis 20 ans il ya un certain
nombre de joueuses au moins une
vingtaine qui ont joué ont évolué après
en division 2 voire en juin au niveau
amateur le nombre des licenciés filles
ne cesse de croître et les clubs comme
ici le racisme besançon recrutent les
féminines depuis peu une des joueuses
officie même comme arbitre chez les
filles et les garçons profit les
j'ai choisi les jouets sera le moins que
les garçons souvent parce que elle
simule mans aussi les garçons n'ont pas
hésité à percuter quoi que ce soit à
dribbler fais mien c'est pas plus dans
le collectif
tu seras cohésion fait du stop qui
dérivent sur son huitième on vient sur
les vraies valeurs du foot c'est à dire
que on retrouve le jeu était les
féminines ça joue au ballon il n'y a pas
de discussion sur le terrain il ya tarif
on pose le ballon se replace c'est des
vrais valeurs du foot allez on met du
rythme nous plaît
depuis la victoire de la france en
russie le nombre de footballeuses a
augmenté de 15% en toute logique les
filles de l'équipe nationale devrait
encore booster les chiffres
est-ce que vous passez un effet coupe du
monde
je pense que ça peut que contribuer à
l'histoire du foot féminin d'une manière
à supplémentaires on va dire et puis je
pense que comme souvent après une coupe
du monde peut-être qu'en termes des
licenciés ça risque de d'avoir
effectivement une incidence et ça peut
être que profitable pour le foot féminin
à partir de septembre 2019
on aura encore plus de licenciés chez
les filles quel que soit le parcours de
l'équipe de france après une belle fête
pour avoir organisé sur notre territoire
évolution des mentalités ouverture des
clubs
nos deux reporters n'ont plus aucun
doute à l'issue de leur rendez vous il
faut s'y mettre